we have already spent dozens of hours
with Diablo 4 and as you can imagine
there are a ton of systems and gameplay
mechanics in this action RPG that can
take some time to wrap your head around
fortunately based on that extensive play
time we've been able to put together
some tips and tricks for you ahead of
launch to make your arrival in sanctuary
a little less hellish here are 14 things
we wish we knew about Diablo 4 before
playing
you'll be posed with some questions
early as you finalize your character
including if you want a more guided or
less guided experience as well as what
world tier you want to play on I would
suggest if you've played action RPGs
before to play on world tier 2. as
you'll get 15 percent more gold from
Monsters as well as 20 percent more
experience the game is tuned pretty well
and World tier 2 is worth the benefits
listed also you can always lower the
difficulty in town if you're feeling
it's too difficult or a boss encounter
becomes too challenging
choosing a class is never easy but I
would say pick the class that represents
the play style that best fits you the
Barbarian gets up close and personal
with his devastating melee attacks
coupled with his shouts that buff
himself and his teammates the sorcerer
is a classic spellcasting class who
wields ice fire and lightning The
Necromancer is the main Summoner class
this time around and is great for more
beginner players as its minions can help
aid you in battle and draw aggro just be
wary of the big bosses as corpses can
sometimes be hard to come by the Druid
is a hybrid class who wields both
Elemental skills can transform for melee
attacks and can summon wolves to Aid
them in battle finally there's the Rogue
who is also a hybrid between Quick Melee
dashing attacks and ranged attacks with
their bow experiment around and see what
fits your play style the best the game
will provide you with the ability to
skip right to the end game on another
character once you complete the campaign
on your first playthrough so don't feel
like you're missing out if you're having
a tough time choosing the game removes
barriers to entry and provides a ton of
incentives to playing with multiple
characters especially as it expands with
additional seasons of content make sure
to synergize your skills by picking up
the passive abilities that they have
these passive abilities really enhance
the skills so make sure to spend points
there before picking another skill
remember too that you'll only be able to
use six skills actively so don't spread
your skill points everywhere respecting
is a relatively low cost to start so
experiment and find what feels the best
for you or if you get some new gear
respect to synergize with that piece of
equipment when analyzing your gear drops
don't equip simply based on the Green
green or red plus and minus armor or
damage while a green item is usually
better especially with weapons early on
it's still important to take a look at
the item in comparison to your current
item to see what other benefits there
are the attributes on a red piece of
gear could be way more beneficial to
your character these attributes include
plus points to skills critical damage
Elemental damage attack speed Critical
Strike Etc if you're really trying to
build an optimized character keeping
these attributes in mind is imperative
Diablo 4 removes the ability to view the
world map as a transparent layer over
top your gameplay so you can still
control your character whilst viewing it
however pinning an objective marker on
it gives you a nice red line on the
minimap to indicate where to go
something you should frequently take
advantage of
Alters of Lilith are littered throughout
the map in various locations there's a
fair amount to find in each region it's
worth finding these altars as they will
net you free passive bonuses from stat
points like dexterity strength
intelligence as well as more health and
a higher capacity for murmuring obals a
currency will get into later in the
video keep an eye out for these as you
explore however if you want to save time
you can always go to gamespot.com where
we'll be putting up location guides for
these Alters
you'll also start to see dungeons appear
on the map as you explore the regions
and Sanctuary keep an eye out on the
aspects of power these Grand aspects of
Power are legendary effects that can be
class specific or available to all the
classes this is a great way to get a
legendary quicker by imprinting this
aspect on the appropriate gear these
aspects will generally enhance a skill
that you're already using or one that
you haven't tried out yet once you see a
dungeon that has an aspect of power you
think you'd like to use on your
character hop in there and beat it so
you can imprint that power on a piece of
your gear one small Pro tip you can add
the leave dungeon emote to your emote
wheel this makes getting out of dungeons
quicker a good aspect to get early on in
your adventures is the aspect of
protection which is found in the Lost
archives in act 1. this legendary effect
will give you a barrier of protection
once you've damaged an elite minion boss
that absorbs X damage for 10 seconds
every 30 seconds if you want to imprint
these items earlier on in your journey
you'll want to make sure you're
salvaging your rares instead of selling
them
make sure to keep an eye out for all
deposits and herbs as they'll be needed
for crafting elixirs as well as
upgrading your potions gems weapons and
armor Harvest them any chance you get
speaking of upgrading your weapons and
armor the first few upgrades are
relatively inexpensive but I would be
mindful that as you continue to progress
through your journey early on that
you'll get newer pieces of gear that
will probably replace your current gear
so be selective on upgrading your pieces
upgrading does help increase your damage
on your weapons and improve armor though
so if you're struggling with a boss or
an encounter upgrading could be the
difference between winning and losing
The Alchemist will have a list of
elixirs that you'll be able to make to
help you in your battles through
Sanctuary that elixes themselves last
for 30 minutes give you a buff and also
give you a five percent experience bonus
since you'll probably have an abundance
of herbs it's probably worth making some
just for the experience buff alone there
will be Alters in the world where you'll
be given a riddle and in order to answer
these riddles you'll need to stand in
the circle and perform an emote that
answers the riddle you'll receive a
small Limited Time Buff from these
make sure you explore each region
because as you discover new areas altars
of Lilith Waypoint side quests Dungeons
and strongholds all of which will give
you Renown for the region the rewards
from improving your Renown are not only
given to the character that you're
playing as but any additional characters
that you have or create in the future
there are five rewards total per region
the first reward is an additional skill
point the second is a plus one to potion
capacity the third is another additional
skill point the fourth is plus 80 to
your murmuring herbals capacity and the
fifth is four Paragon points do notes
that the fourth and fifth Renown
upgrades require you to have beaten the
game and unlock World tier 3. the
quickest way to level up to the third
Renown upgrade is by completing all
three strongholds in each region as they
each give you 100 Renown points which is
three quarters of the requirement to
finishing the third tier of renown
beware though if you are playing on
world tier 2 that strongholds are
usually a level or two above your
current level and generally have a
strong boss at the end of them as noted
above though if you're struggling you
can always lower the world's tier
completing public events denoted by
orange circles in the map will provide
you with murmuring ovals which can be
taken to the purveyor of curiosity to
gamble for items this is a great way to
get legendary items your initial Max
Capacity for murmuring ovals is 500 but
you'll be able to increase this down the
road by increasing your Renown in the
regions Lilith statues and more what I
would suggest is to farm up to 300 to
500 then head back and focus on one
piece of gear at a time the cheaper
pieces of equipment to gamble on are
offhands gloves boots pants and helmets
since these are only 40 herbals each I'd
focus on upgrading those pieces first
since you'll get more mileage out of
your ovals and legendary earlier on will
probably sustain you a good chunk of
time so upgrades that piece then the
next and rinse and repeat the purveyor
also sells Whispering keys for 20
murmuring ovals which open up silent
chests that you can find in the world
for me I opened a few of these and never
got anything more than a rare or two so
my advice would be to spend your ovals
on gambling instead of these keys
all that exploring would be a lot easier
with a noble Steed and while the latest
iteration of Diablo does provide mounts
unfortunately you will not acquire one
till a while into the game you'll visit
the city of kyovichard early in the
campaign there you'll come across a
stable Master who's got a quest called
donen's favor here's the kicker even
though the quest appears at this early
stage in the game you won't be able to
complete it until the beginning of act
four once you reach that point you'll
receive a main quest called a master's
touch in it you'll need to talk to Donan
at the Cathedral of light in kyovichard
after speaking to Donan go back to the
stable master and he'll have the old
Nell Steed available for use there are
also two others the gray Steed and
mottled Seed which you can purchase for
20 000 gold each
and those are all the things you need to
know before tackling demons and
Sanctuary stay tuned to Gamespot for a
bunch more coverage around Diablo 4 and
remember dreamhack Dallas is happening
this week with Esports cosplay voice
actors DND fighting games and so much
more to bring the gaming Community to
life use code dream big at checkout to
save 20 percent
foreign